all right Pam is with us in Cincinnati
hi Pam how are you I'm fine how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I
call what IVA well maybe not unique but
my husband and I we've been married
20-some years and I guess 28 it would be
and I did all the finances for the
better part of those years recently last
five years he went a period of time
where he was unemployed was really
really wreak havoc on our finances and
now he is gainfully employed and doing
well but he tries to make up for not
having had money in the difficult times
by paying things now since I'm the
budget person I know what all needs to
be paid but then he'll go ahead and make
like a huge payment on something else
which then will withdraw our account or
do something else
devastating you two aren't doing your
budget together well and I've tried I
will write it all down I'll say here is
no no no no no no no that's not how you
do it you can't write it all down and
tell him what to do I don't we've been
to your stuff we've been to your things
twice he says he's all-in but he's the
one that's like yeah yeah yeah I'll show
up at the meeting and he'll say yeah
whatever that's great that's great but
then that's not great because then he
doesn't follow what we just said okay
stop stop stop stop stop stop
so the problem is you're not doing the
budget correctly you're not listening
the budget done correctly is both of you
are looking at the numbers before the
month begins every dollar has a name and
then you both agree this is what we're
going to do with the money now if he
can't keep that agreement then he hasn't
understood in the budget committee
meeting that this is a contract you may
want to put two lines at the bottom of
the budget and both of you sign it and
say do not do anything else with money
except what's on this without coming
back and you and I correcting it
together if you do anything other than
this I'm gonna be all in your stuff
because I hear you I hear you and we've
done all of that we've been okay then
you have a problem with your husband
being a liar and you need marriage
counseling
and that's what I would say and we've
talked about that I said this is you
know you got a sick with this it's like
he's oblivious and I don't know how to
get him he has not heard that this is
ideal
he hasn't [ __ ] II swear spit shake made
a contract with you I'm telling you
because that or he absolutely has no
integrity and oblivious is not lack of
integrity oblivious as he didn't
understand that this is a big freakin
deal this is like you lying to me right
we have a contract here and you're gonna
really you're gonna have to finish the
Budget Committee meeting with that a few
times and then if he just goes and does
whatever he wants to do and lies to you
and breaks the contract then you need to
go see a marriage counselor really
because I mean that that's not oblivious
then that that's a you know that's just
being aggressively an aggressive
straight up you know liar I'm gonna do
whatever I want to do your vote doesn't
count all this doing a budget together
doesn't matter I'll sit down looking at
it I make my decisions and to heck with
your opinion well that's no way to be
married now he's not doing that though
because you're Pam the truth is you've
not gotten through to him that this is a
contract and that you consider this
lying when he doesn't stick to the
contract that's what you've got to
communicate to him because guys I listen
I'm one of them you ladies aren't
masters of subtlety and you you think
you've said something and we had any
more hurt it than fly the moon I mean
you with a guy you have to throw a brick
through the window to get his he has to
oh okay I got it now and once we get it
we get it but he has not heard you I'll
guarantee you you think you're being
blunt you're not even close to blunt
you're so subtle you're so
passive-aggressive you're not even
saying it you got a look in his eyes and
go contract I'm gonna slit your freaking
throat buddy I'm gonna kill you do not
lie to me
you got you got oh that's how you look
at this okay and I don't know what
language you're gonna use in your
situation but you know what when it's a
big deal you have to make sure he knows
it's a big deal
that's not oblivious you can't be
oblivious when you've had a conversation
like that and so that's where this is
breaking down the closing of the budget
committee meeting is where this is
breaking down and then you guys just
both go do whatever the flip you want to
do that's just not gonna work
you